[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT MCGOWEN: All
right, everyone.
Thanks for coming out.
Let's go ahead and get started.
My name is Brett McGowen.
And I'm a developer advocate
at Google for the Google Cloud
Platform.
You can follow me here
on Twitter @brettmcg.
So a little bit
more about myself.
Like I said, I'm a
developer advocate focusing
on the Google Cloud platform.
I work in the New
York City office.
But I do have to say even
though I live in New York,
I'm from Texas.
AUDIENCE: Yee haw!
BRETT MCGOWEN: Yes, much better.
Yes.
How do you know if
someone is from Texas?
AUDIENCE: They'll tell you.
BRETT MCGOWEN: Don't worry.
They'll tell you.
All right.
So I'm going talk
about Cloud Spin today.
And Cloud Spin is
this demo that's
over here to my
left that is set up
to show off some
of the technology
that we have in the
Google Cloud platform.
And we thought it would be
pretty cool, instead of just
walking through
a bunch of slides
and showing off a bunch of
the features that we have.
What if we actually
built something?
And then I'll walk
you through what
we built, why we chose
what we did as we built it.
And hopefully you can take that
away into your own projects
and understand maybe
how you can leverage
the power of the Google Cloud
platform in your own work.
So this is my chance.
This is my chance for
fake fame and fake glory.
I got to be a fake
CEO for three weeks.
I always wanted to be a CEO.
And now, I could sell
a product that no one
would pay for that's
going absolutely nowhere.
So it's not a real
product from Google.
This is just a tech demo.
It's a fun thing to show off
and give material for this talk.
So it's not going to get
released in the Play store.
We're not going to charge it.
But that was a story I wanted
to tell, like we're a startup.
And we wanted to
approach it that way.
This is for real.
We want to think about
costs like a startup would.
We want to think about time
to market like a startup would
and really, like
a developer would.
You want to spend your
time writing code.
You don't want to spend your
time managing infrastructure,
orchestrating things
like from a cloud
perspective, virtual
machines, things like that.
So we had three weeks.
We were specifically
building this
for a series of events
called GCP Next, which
we did in a bunch of
cities around the US
and around the world.
We wanted a fun demo to show
off, make it interactive,
and help teach people
about the cloud.
So we thought, all
right, this is the market
we're going to disrupt.
It's photo booths.
So instead of a
photo booth you guys
have seen probably in the mall.
They have them at bar mitzvahs
and birthdays and weddings.
You get in this photo booth, and
you-- no, you and your friend
get in this photo-- no, you
and your five or six friends
cram in this tiny photo booth.
And you're all wearing a
Viking and giant sunglasses
and a big feather boa.
And then it counts down--
one, two, three, click.
One, two, three, click.
And then it prints out that
little strip of photos.
You guys know what
I'm talking about?
So that was our dream.
We're going to revolutionize
the photo booth industry.
And we're going to make
something worthy of 2016,
a 3D, floating,
spinning photo booth.
So this is our dream.
And we call it Cloud Spin.
So first, we had to get
to designing Cloud Spin.
So this is our
engineering diagram.
You can tell it's an engineering
diagram because it has numbers.
For example, I had to remember
what on Earth a radius was when
we were putting this together.
So this outlays how it works.
We've got 19 Nexus 6 phones.
It's 180 degrees.
One phone every 10 degrees.
So we took this.
We sent it to marketing.
And we said, all
right, this is what
we want to do for our demo.
They said, OK, we've
made a few minor changes.
Looks very different.
You can see there is
no numbers on this.
That's because this is
the marketing diagram.
This is the engineering diagram.
This is the marketing diagram.
I worked on this one.
But you can see in
the end who won.
Clearly, marketing won
because it looks exactly
like the diagram they gave.
This the first time I've
ever given this talk
where I actually had a picture
of it right next to it.
So it's an inception
moment right now.
So don't be confused.
That's the real one over there.
This is just for display.
So this was our goal.
This was the final product.
But let me talk you
through how we got there.
So how does this
work, conceptually?
So the first thing
that happens is
the user gets in the center
of the phones in the cameras.
They jump up, and then
they all take a picture
at the exact same second.
And then we stitch it together,
and we make that animated
graphic that you saw.
So sounds super-easy, right?
It's a very short talk.
Actually, it's pretty tricky.
And we ran into a lot of
problems along the way.
But let me talk
about what are some
of the things we were trying to
solve, some problems to solve.
One is literally just
how do you take a picture
at the exact same second
across all these phones?
That sounds easy.
But we'll talk about some of
the challenges you ran into.
What are some of the
other challenges?
Just coordinating all the
phones together, just 20 things.
That's a lot of
data to move around
to worry about synchronizing.
The app needs to
report, am I my crashed?
Am I working?
Am I uploading?
Am I on Wi-Fi?
What is my status?
So that's another thing
we have to worry about.
File storage-- we had to
put these videos somewhere.
We had to put the
images somewhere.
We have to do
something with that.
Scale-- so in our
fake start up world,
we're going to be
unbelievably successful.
We're going to be in bars
across-- bars-- well,
maybe some bars-- I'm thinking
about the after party.
They're going to be in
malls across the country
and the world, right?
So we've got to scale up.
Another thing we think
about is image processing.
How do we actually
process all these images?
Where do we do that?
How does that work?
And how does that tie
into everything else?
We need to think about
controlling cost,
like as a startup.
We don't have unlimited
funds to run this.
So we have to think,
how can we run
as minimal resources
as possible while
still being able to scale
up when this inevitably
becomes wildly successful?
What if we want to
create multiple versions?
So right now, this one just
has kind of one version where
they're frozen in the air.
And I'll show you
some variations
maybe that we could do.
So we had to think about how
do we architect our system
to make that happen?
And then just debugging and
logging, not that anything
has ever gone wrong in
the history of software.
But if something goofs up and
something is down or something
crashes, how do we find
out the state of things?
And then how do we fix it?
All right, so taking the photos.
So this is how do
we get 19 cameras
to take a photo all
at the exact second?
Any ideas?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You tell them all
to take it at a certain time
according to a clock.
BRETT MCGOWEN: Yes,
so you tell them
everyone take a photo at
this exact time, right?
And you can even give it an epic
time stamp to the millisecond,
and tell them all to do that.
But here's the catch.
They're all slightly off.
So if you look at
the time, they all
seem to be on the same time.
But actually, when you
get down to that level,
even if they're all
in network time,
there's a little
bit of variance.
And so we have to get
within 20 milliseconds.
Otherwise, this one will
have me at this position.
But the next one,
I'll be falling down.
And the next one,
But then the third
one took earlier.
So it's a very jagged effect,
so within 20 milliseconds.
But that was the
first thing we tried
was just using time and
sending it to all of them.
Any other ideas how
we could do that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Video frames.
BRETT MCGOWEN: So
video frames, OK.
So what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Take a piece of
video and try to match up
the frames together.
BRETT MCGOWEN: Yeah, so
this is a good idea-- video,
and then try to match them up.
Any other ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRETT MCGOWEN: I'm sorry.
Send a what signal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRETT MCGOWEN: OK, so you can
send a push signal and say,
take it now.
We also tried that.
And we tried it with a product
called Firebase, which I'll
talk about in a little bit.
The problem with that is even
super-fast response times,
just random internet network
traffic, even if they're
all in the same local
network, is enough variance
that you run into the
jagged frame of effect
where they're not taking it
all at the exact same time.
So what we ended up
doing is-- oh yeah.
Here's one of the
things I talked about.
So we need to
coordinate 19 phones.
So an issue that we
ran into is that even
if we had some magic
technology that
could send a command
to every phone
at the exact same nanosecond--
take a photo-- they all
got the command at the exact
same trillionth of a second
in time-- there's
a random hardware
delay that we can't control.
And that is actually varied
enough to disrupt our video.
So that was a huge problem.
So any kind of
time-based solution
was basically off the
table at that point
because even if
in a perfect world
we could get them to
coordinate, we'd say now.
So camera 1 would
take it instantly.
Camera 2 would take it
ah, now, even if they
got it the exact same second.
So that was really
difficult to deal with.
So what we ended up
doing is taking a video.
So this is my coworker Ray.
He worked with me
on this project.
He was actually
giving this talk.
And I snuck this video
in without him knowing.
And he almost
murdered me afterwards
because he was like,
I can't believe
I had to give this
talk with me jumping
like an idiot for a minute.
So ever since then, I've made
sure to put it in every talk
because it just
makes me so happy.
So this is it.
Basically, this is an animated
GIF of him jumping up and down.
And it's a video.
So a video is essentially like
a burst mode-- frame, frame,
frame, frame, frame.
So if you get enough cameras
doing frame, frame, frame,
frame, frame, frame, inevitably
some frame on each camera
will be the same moment in time.
So then we have to come up
with a problem like, how do we
know which frame will match up?
How do we identify the frames?
There's a few ways
we wanted to do it.
One was flash.
So we could maybe have
like a bright flash.
And then we could
analyze the video
and we could say, oh,
which frame is slightly
brighter than the others?
And then once we found
that bright frame,
we know that that's
the same moment
in time across all the cameras.
But that was hard too because
there's very different lighting
environments that we were in.
Some places are super-bright.
And we'd have to get a crazy
bright flash to make it work.
Also, it was hard for
us to get a flash that
sat nicely in one frame.
So sometimes it would kind of
bleed over into two frames.
And then it started
getting wonky
because this one's a
little bit brighter.
And this one is a
little bit darker.
So it was a little bit tricky.
I tried using timestamp,
maybe like an NTP server
so they could all say, I know
my offset is slightly different.
And if I'm picking this
time from the server that
says, use frame 0 plus
2 seconds or whatever,
it could find it that way.
But that turned
out to be tricky.
Like I said, we only
had three weeks.
So what we went is
with an audio marker.
So you guys have seen
in old-timey movies--
not even old-timey, current
time, the clapboard, right?
So if a scene is
about to happen,
they say Cloud Spin--
the Movie, take 76, clap.
Right?
And it's got a timestamp on it.
And they use that so that all
the different cameras that
are pointed at the same moment
can sync up their audio.
So essentially, we took
that idea and used that.
We immediately ran into a
few issues, one of which
is-- did anyone have an Android
and iPhone back in the day?
And you would have
the headphones
that had the little mic.
And it worked on iPhone,
but not on Android.
And it worked on Android,
but not on iPhone.
You guys know what
I'm talking about?
It works now, but
back then it didn't.
So it turns out there's two
different standards in case
you're curious.
The one of the left is
created by, I think,
Nokia back in the day.
And so it's got these bands.
So the left signal,
right signal, microphone,
and the ground.
So then when the iPhone
came out, Apple innovated.
And they switched
the bottom two.
I don't know why, but they did.
So that caused us
no end of headache.
So we had to figure that out.
And I just thought that
was an amusing thing.
So we said, how do we
get this audio signal
into all of these phones?
So I went to one
of my coworkers.
And he was like,
Brett, I got it.
So he goes to the white board.
He's frantically drawing on it.
He draws this crazy scheme.
He says, come check it out.
I've got the solution for how to
split the audio signal into all
those cameras, into
all those phones.
And I walk and I said, what?
I have no idea what this is.
I'm not an audio engineer.
Can you explain this to me?
And he said, ah, I'll
do something better.
I will make you a device
that splits the audio.
I was like, all right, cool.
So he leaves.
And two days later,
he comes back.
And he gives me this.
I still don't know
what to do with this.
All I know is how to plug things
into the top of the phone.
Can we work with that?
We tried to get this to work.
It didn't.
And to this day, it sits
on my coworker's desk just
taunting me of our failure.
Where do you plug something in?
I have no idea.
So we actually ended up using
off-the-shelf components.
So this is a normal
audio splitter.
Actually, I got one of
these at a vending machine
in the airport.
So it's totally off the shelf.
And we basically have one
tablet that plays a beep.
It gets split once
into four splitters,
and then from those
splitters gets split
five times into each phone.
So that's how we can
take an audio marker
and split it into all 19 phones.
So again, the objective
of what we're doing
is each camera is
taking a video.
And we're going to play
a beep on one frame
at the exact same time
across all the phones.
I will play this video.
And we don't have audio.
So I will emulate
the beep for you.
Beep.
Yeah.
So you can imagine that beep
actually being a beep going
into all the phones.
All right.
So now, we conceptually
have how we're
going to mark the frame
across all of them.
How do we actually coordinate
between all those phones?
That's a lot to deal with.
It's really complicated.
So we tried to
write it manually.
It ended up being a
huge pain in the butt.
And after a day of lost
productivity, said forget this.
We need to do something else.
So just to get into a little bit
of what we had to coordinate,
there was a bunch of stuff.
One is just camera app status.
Am I ready?
Am I uploading?
Am I crashed, heaven forbid?
So that's things that
cameras need to report out.
We also needed to get some
settings into the cameras.
So we need to do things like
ISO or shutter speed, exposure.
So if we're in different
lighting environments,
like it's a little bit darker
now versus brighter later,
we want to be able
to change some value
and instantly have
all the phones pick up
those new values for the camera.
Internal versus external mic.
Like I said, we're feeding the
audio signal into every phone.
So we need to know if
one comes unplugged
and is just using ambient
noise from around us.
We need to know about
that because it's
going to pick up a very
different peak audio
signal than everything else.
We want we want everything
to be isolated just
in that audio cable so that
it's quiet except for the beep.
And then a timestamp
to start the recording.
So we need to tell
them like, hey,
by such and such time-- we
were talking about timestamp
earlier-- it's not necessarily
the definitive time
of the photo.
But by this time, you
need to be recording.
So we want to communicate
that to all those phones.
And for this, we used Firebase.
Has anyone used Firebase?
Are we familiar with it all?
Yes.
So Firebase is awesome.
I highly encourage
you to check it out.
At its most basic level,
it's a NoSQL JSON database.
But the thing that it
does that's super magical
is near real-time,
near instantaneous
updates across all
subscribers to the database.
So by way of example, we want
to have all the phones share
the same timestamp for when
they're recording a video.
So we can write that
value in Firebase.
And within less than
a second typically,
all the phones have
gotten that value.
And it happens super-magically.
I'll show you that code
in a second-- one second,
here it is.
So here it is.
So we're just instantiating--
this is the Android code.
So this is the code that
is running on the camera.
And it is communicating its
status and its app version
up to Firebase so that our
control app or our visualizer
or somebody can
take a look at it.
So we just create a
new Firebase instance.
We point it to a URL.
So here it would be whatever
Firebase is /cameras/7 would be
camera 7.
This is just a plain
old Java object.
There's nothing magic.
And then you say camera
status camerasStatusRef
.setValue(nCameraStatus).
And within less
than a second, that
has been communicated
up to the server.
So here is the reverse.
So here is I am
on my control app.
This is the control
app on the left.
So the green is the app state.
So green is good.
Green is ready.
It also has the app
version embedded in there.
And then that's with an
internal or external mic.
So the settings is in Firebase.
So these are, again, the
ISO, the exposure, the tone.
So we can play
some specific tone
if we find that a
higher tone gets
picked up more easily or
a lower tone or so forth.
Our frequency is 2,600 Hertz.
If you don't know what
that is, look it up.
I will not talk
about this on stage.
So how does it work?
So there's a Start
Countdown button.
So I hit the button.
And here, it's eight seconds.
So we're going to count
down for eight seconds.
So it will take
eight seconds, add it
to the current timestamp, and
update this value in Firebase.
And, again, within
less than a second,
every phone now has
the time that it
knows it needs to be recording.
So how did it actually
record the video?
Where did that code come from?
This was a project on GitHub.
And it's called
Android Camera2Video.
And it is put out by Google
as sort of a sample reference
project for how to record
video with a camera.
So what I did is I used this to
learn the API, by which I mean
I copied and pasted, and pretty
much verbatim just stuck it
in the app.
But in all seriousness,
it actually
is a great project
to learn the API,
even though I'm embarrassed
that I pretty much just
copied out of it.
All right, so let's talk
a little bit about cloud.
So here's our team.
So I'm in New York
City, like I mentioned.
My coworker Ray, he's
the guy with the camera.
We worked on the Android
stuff in New York.
And we said, OK, it's
time to work on cloud.
So we do what all
good development
teams do, and we outsourced it.
So we gave it to our colleague
in San Francisco and said,
hey, let us know how it goes.
No, just kidding-- well, mostly.
So I just wanted
to show you that.
And I'll talk a bit in
a second like what we
used to make this more easily.
But using cloud,
it was easy for us
to have distributed
development teams.
We can all work on things
without mucking around too much
with API definition
and things like that.
Again, we wanted to
build and build quickly--
the theme of this talk.
So here's our architecture.
We have the devices.
Each one takes a video and
uploads it to an input bucket.
So this is a storage
bucket of some kind.
Then the input bucket from
there, somebody needs to know,
hey, there's something
to do with something.
We need to notify somebody.
So that's a
notification processor.
Then we want to
take that request
and we want to stick it
in a queue of some kind.
We don't want to work
on it right away.
I'll talk a little
bit more about why.
But mostly, it's because if
we get flooded with requests
and we don't have enough
resources to keep up,
we want to stick those
requests in a queue
so they don't get lost.
And then we can
pick them up later.
From there, we're
going to extract it.
So we're going to look
at the audio signal.
We're going to find that one
frame that has that beep.
We're going to put
into a stitching queue
when it's done so that when
all the frames are done,
we're going to actually
take all of them.
So these are all the
individual frames
that have been extracted.
And we will stitch them together
into a final animated GIF.
So I walk through this in a
little more detail as we go.
So the first step, video uploads
and notification processing.
So, again, file storage, we
have to put this somewhere.
These are the three Google
Cloud platform storage options,
or three of them, Cloud
Datastore, Cloud SQL, and Cloud
Storage.
So what are these?
So Cloud Datastore is a NoSQL
managed database from Google.
We use it internally,
a similar technology,
to do about 4.5 trillion
operations a month.
So it's very, very scalable
and very, very fast.
Cloud SQL is managed MySQL.
So what is Cloud Storage?
Cloud Storage is where you can
put cat videos or, in our case,
jumping people videos.
So this is binary storage so
you can put blobs of whatever.
So you can have
massive file sizes.
Ours are like maybe
10 or 20 megs.
But you can put a gig or a
terabyte or whatever of data
that you want.
Here's the code to
get into to upload it.
So, again, this is
on the Android side.
So the Android has finished
recording the video
and now wants to upload
it to cloud storage.
So I left off the credentials
so you cannot hack me.
But this is essentially
a service account
that we had that we
used for Cloud Spin.
But you can also use OAuth 2
to have maybe an individual use
their own credentials on the
phone or something like that.
You point it to your
project and then set
the MIME type, so video MP4.
I'm not going to get into
the weeds in this code,
but just show you generally
what it looks like.
And then you execute.
And you upload.
So then what happens
after you upload?
We need to tell an API that
there's a video to work on.
So this is something called
Object Change Notifications
that we have in
Google Cloud Storage.
And what that does is rather
than the phone calling an API
and saying, hey, I just uploaded
this video to the cloud,
we actually have the storage
mechanism do it for us.
So this was nice working
in the distributed team
because I had no idea what the
next step in the process was.
I just uploaded my video to
the Cloud Storage bucket.
And then my colleague
in San Francisco
had configured it so
it would automatically
call the API, the next
step in the chain.
So that's really nice.
So you can configure that.
It's also good so if you move
where that endpoint lives
to a different service or
a different cloud provider
or a different region
or different whatever,
you can change the storage
mechanism where you
are uploading the videos to.
And you don't have to upload
your APK on your Android
device.
So it's just uploading
to the same place.
It doesn't need to know
there's a new API endpoint.
So that's really nice.
So three options for Google
Cloud Storage-- standard,
reduced availability,
and nearline.
I'm not going to get
too salesy on this,
but from a developer
perspective, what
does this mean?
One, they all share the same
API, which is super-nice.
So as you're
developing apps, you
don't have to rework your
API design or consumption,
depending on which
storage option you use.
Standard storage is
our standard storage,
standard online storage.
And the nearline is our
equivalent to a tape storage.
So this would be your
archival thing, so
things you don't need
access to immediately.
So you'll notice that the
speed drops down as you
go left to right, as does cost.
So to give you a sense
of how slow is nearline,
it's like on the order
of four to two seconds,
something like that.
So it's actually, compared to a
lot of other long-term storage
options from other cloud
providers is pretty fast.
Four seconds to get essentially
your long-term search storage
is excellent.
One other things we'll
talk about is edge caching.
There's another feature
of Google Cloud Storage.
So what this is is as
users from around the world
are requesting files
from your storage system,
it will automatically
propagate them
to data centers near
them physically.
So that will reduce
their load times.
So you can imagine if
we take this contraption
and make a huge social
network around it,
as people around the
world are requesting
to see other people's images or
whatever, it will automatically
propagate those to
data centers that
are closer to where they are.
And it does it automatically.
It's not a CDN.
It's not like a
guaranteed cache.
But it is sort of a
best-effort cache.
And it's kind of nice because
you get it essentially
out of the box.
So the next thing I'm going
to talk about is App Engine.
Has anyone used App Engine
or heard of App Engine?
Yeah, a few of us.
So this is probably our
most popular platform
as a service offering.
I like to say the dream of App
Engine is you write your code
and then you upload
it, and it just runs.
It scales up to as
high as you need
and scales down to essentially
zero if you don't need
anything.
So this is nice.
So you don't have to worry
about what's the load on my app?
Do I need to have certain
metrics like my CPU
is spiking across my cluster.
So I need to have some process
to automatically scale this out
to more machines.
It supports Python, PHP,
Java, and Go out of the box.
And then there's some ways
to do Node.js as well.
It does some cool things
too like versioning.
So you can say, hey, I want
to give 20% of my visitors
this version of the code.
I want to give 80% this version.
So you can do some A/B
testing that way to see
which one performs better.
And the most important
thing is it's
managed by Google
SREs, which means
if there needs to be
security patches rolled out--
if your app needs to scale up
from 1 to 2 to 3 to 10 servers,
App Engine just takes
care of it for you.
And if it goes down,
the Google SREs
are monitoring all of
that infrastructure,
and they will fix it.
You don't have to worry about
individual machines going down.
Our team is managing it for you.
All right.
So speaking of scale,
here's this dude.
He's rocking out
on his air guitar.
Maybe he's in Austin, Texas.
Here's a dude
fighting an Android.
He's maybe in Amsterdam.
Here's some team doing a team
building exercise in Japan.
These are actually
all real photos.
But say it gets this popular.
It's around the world.
And people are
doing wacky things.
And we have to start
worrying about scale.
So this is no longer one
setup with some minor amount
of infrastructure.
This is getting real, y'all.
Our fake startup
is getting real.
It's still fake.
So how do we do that?
So we need to put things
into a queue of some kind
to absorb those requests so
that we can store them and work
on them later.
Let's do a quick thing--
push versus pull.
So push is like requests
go into the queue.
And then the queue
finds someone to tell.
And then it tells them.
That's a push.
A pull is it goes
into the queue,
and then someone who becomes
available-- so some process
or whatever that's
available to work on it
will then ask, hey,
give me the next item.
In our instance, we're going
to use a pull subscription
because we want to scale
up as many image processors
as we want and then
scale them down.
And then they'll take care
of requesting the next thing.
So for this, we used a
product called Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub can be used for
a lot of things, one of which
is a queue.
At the end of the
day, ultimately, it's
a publish subscribe system.
And I'll show you what that
looks like in a second.
But this is a fully
managed service by Google.
So if you have messages you
need to put into a queue
or whatever, you can
use Cloud Pub/Sub.
And you don't have to
install any software.
You don't have to spin
up any virtual machines.
You don't have to worry about
how big your node cluster is
or anything like that.
You turn it on, and you can
start pushing messages into it
or receiving them.
So how does it work?
We have an extractor.
In our case, the
extractor is the process
that looks at the video.
And it's finding that one
frame that has that beep.
So it's analyzing
the audio track
looking for the beep-- so frame
1, frame 2, frame 3, frame
4, and so on.
So once it finds the
right frame with the beep,
it's pulling that
frame out into a JPEG.
So that's our extractor.
So once it has that
frame extracted,
it's going to put it
into a frames topic
so that, ultimately,
once they're all done,
someone else can pick that up
and stitch them all together.
So in this case,
we have a stitcher.
A stitcher is the process
that takes all the frames
and puts them together.
And it's listening
on that frames topic.
So once the extractor is
done, it posts a message,
and the stitcher picks it up.
So here is what our
original stitcher creates.
It is essentially
what you see here.
It's spinning from left
or right or whatever.
And he's like frozen in
the air the whole time.
But say we wanted
to do variations.
Say we wanted to do like
other versions of Cloud Spin
besides just one frozen in air.
So we could do that
easily with Cloud Pub/Sub
by having other stitchers that
create alternate versions also
listening to that frames topic.
So the extractor still is
just publishing one message.
It doesn't know who is even
consuming it on the other side.
It doesn't need to know that
there's one, two, three now
instead of just one.
So let's see what
these could look
like with some other variations.
So here's one that
actually takes the video
from the first camera.
I guess it's using the
center camera, stops,
and it's going to spin
all the way to the left,
all the way back to
the right, and then
use the video on the right one.
So that's different.
So there's actually
movement in this GIF
rather than just
the initial one.
And then, similarly, you can
start at one of the ends,
spin all the way over, and
then finish and play the video.
So those are some variations
we can do with Cloud Spin.
And with Pub/Sub, again,
you publish one message
to the topic.
And then however many stitchers
have different versions,
they subscribe to that
topic and stitch them later.
So let's go back to
some interesting photos.
So while we're all building
on this cloud infrastructure,
we built this off of a
really half-assed prototype.
Now we need to do it for
real because our deadline is
looming.
So let me take you inside
our secret startup lab.
This is in New York in
this other, other building
that no one even knew we
owned or had an office in.
So we were working
in this office.
No one knew who we were.
And we were putting together
this ridiculous prototype.
It was really cheap,
really scrappy,
because we didn't know for
sure that this would work.
And when I say scrappy,
I mean really scrappy.
So these are selfie sticks,
if you can see that.
We literally put a phone
on top of a selfie stick
and used it as a tripod.
I don't know if anyone
has tried to do this.
But it is actually the least
stable way you can possibly
hold up a cell phone.
I would roll over
to my coworkers desk
to tell them something,
and just the wind
of me rolling by
the selfie stick
would cause it to topple over.
And I'd have to
dive under the floor
to save this phone so I didn't
have to explain to my boss
why I smashed a $600 cell
phone on the ground because
of a selfie stick.
So yeah, we set up
a bunch of selfie
sticks to act as
makeshift tripods.
We were trying to find
the right distance
from where the person is to
where the edge of the cameras
are.
And we didn't have
any measuring tape.
I was like, guys, we work for
a multi-billion dollar company.
And we don't have
any measuring tape.
But for some reason, my coworker
had police crime scene tape
in his desk.
To this day, I did not ask
because I don't actually
want to know why he had
crime scene tape in his desk.
So we had to measure
it out using that.
And it actually turns out
that the ideal distance
between the person
getting their photo
taken and the cameras
is eight CAUTIONs.
A CAUTION is about a foot,
in case you're curious.
A CAUTION unit is
not something that I
was familiar with
until this project.
So, yeah, it was pretty scrappy.
But eventually we
got it working.
We felt like, OK, this is good.
We're feeling good.
And then we said, let's
get some lighting.
So this was our intern Matt.
Matt, super-brilliant guy.
He wrote the first
version of the software
that analyzes the video to
find the frame with the beat.
So he's super-smart.
He's like, guys, I cannot
figure out this lighting.
Can you please help me out?
And so we came over,
and we're like, come on.
We can figure this out.
We could not figure out why
these lights weren't working.
It wasn't until I was putting
this presentation together
that I realized why this
light wasn't working.
It's because it's
not plugged in.
I literally was looking at
this photo, and I went, like,
oh, my god.
That's why we never figured it
out, because it's unplugged.
So I don't know what
this says about me.
But whatever, anyway,
so it was fun.
So we got that all working.
We eventually got
our lights working.
Selfie sticks were not working.
So we got actual tripods.
We went all out.
We bought a full
set of 20 phones.
We set it up in
this little room.
People always ask, why
is it a green screen?
Are you superimposing?
I was like, no, that was just
the color of the curtain.
So yeah, that was
not very exciting.
So it was all good.
We were feeling good about life.
That is, until I tried to use
the bathroom in this office.
So I don't know why.
This has nothing to
do with the project.
I just think it's a terrifying
and hilarious anecdote.
So every time I went
to the bathroom,
there's this picture of
this lady in the wall.
First of all, I don't know why a
super-creepy photo is in there.
I didn't pee for three
weeks, basically.
But all right.
That's creepy, but it's a
regular amount of creepy.
Where it gets super creepy
is if you look more closely,
you see that someone
had cut out her eyes.
And behind her eyes
were more eyes.
There were eyes behind her eyes.
And at first, I thought it
was one of those "Scooby Doo"
cartoon situations where there's
a painting and someone is
watching you from behind it.
But no, it's just
regular painting eyes.
So anyway, do you
all want to stare
at this creepy, terrifying
photo for a while?
No?
Let's move on.
Sure?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRETT MCGOWEN: All right.
All right, so extracting
and stitching.
Back to the real stuff.
These are the bits of the
project that are actually
running the code that's
actually analyzing the video
and finding the frame,
extracting the JPEG,
and the bit that's
stitching them all together.
So once it has all the
JPEGs, stitching it together
into a final, animated GIF.
So here is what that looks like
on the architecture diagram,
the extractor and the stitcher.
So, again, from the phones
to a storage bucket,
it tells App Engine, which
is a notification processor.
It goes into a queue.
And the extractor picks it up.
So what is the extractor doing?
The extractor is looking
at the audio intensity
level of the video clip.
And it's finding the
one frame that is
higher than all the other ones.
Can anyone tell me where
that is on this graph?
Yes.
It is right there
about frame 79.
That's the beep.
So it's basically code that's
looking at the audio level.
And it's finding the one frame
that has the highest beep.
Here's the code.
Again, I'm not going to get
into a ton of detail on it.
But essentially,
we're using a library
called MoviePy,
which is essentially
a Python wrapper around FFmpeg.
So I don't know if you
guys have used FFmpeg.
It's a command line tool to
do all kinds of crazy stuff
with images and
videos and whatnot.
It's super complicated
and super powerful.
So MoviePy is like a
nice wrapper around it.
It's literally a Python script.
It takes a video as an input and
it saves a JPEG as an output .
So the formula here is
it's looking for something
that is more than four times
above the standard deviation
of the audio level of this
frame, for what it's worth.
We've actually changed
it now to where
it's just find the highest
volume, which was much easier.
All right.
So now that extracts one frame.
So we have a whole bunch of
these extractors actually
running in parallel.
So rather than
taking camera one,
finding the frame, camera
two, finding the frame,
this is the cloud.
We're going to spin
up 20 processes,
so they can all pick a video.
And they can all
pull out one frame.
So it can happen
very, very quickly.
So say we've got 20 frames.
They've all been extracted.
Now we need to
stitch them together.
This all runs, incidentally,
on our Compute Engine offering.
So Compute Engine is
our infrastructure
as a service offering.
So what that essentially
means in basic terms
is our virtual machines, right?
You can spin up
a virtual machine
that has CentOS or Debian
or Ubuntu or whatever.
I want this much RAM.
I want this as a hard drive.
I want an SSD.
I want this many
processors that are
this fast-- kind of customize
it to what you want.
So that's called
Google Compute Engine.
So these are virtual
machines you can
install whatever you want on.
They're managed by you.
So one thing-- I want
to put my sales hat back
on for a second-- that I
think is cool about our cloud
is that you can provision
virtual machines super,
super quickly.
And so for a fake
start up project,
this was important
because we kind of
wanted to run as few virtual
machines as possible.
But then we wanted to be ready
that if all of a sudden, Cloud
Spin is in malls all across
America and the world,
and Sunday morning comes and
everyone goes out to the mall
and starts using
it all at once, we
want to be able to scale
up our compute power very,
very quickly.
So when I say fast virtual
machine provisioning,
I'm talking about a
thousand virtual machines
on the order of minutes--
less than 10 minutes,
just a few minutes.
So it's really quick.
So we can keep our resources
low and control costs.
And then when we need to scale
up, we can do it very quickly.
So how do we autoscale that?
So, again, these are
essentially Python scripts
that are running and extracting
images and stitching them
all together to
create this video.
How do we scale that?
We're using a thing called
Compute Engine Autoscaler.
To kind of walk you
through the diagram here--
there's a bunch of boxes-- you
essentially create an instance
group template.
So this is the
recipe of-- this is
what I want my virtual
machine to look like.
I want all the virtual
machines in here,
again, to have
this OS, CPU, RAM.
And then you can have
a startup script.
So say, as soon as this
virtual machine comes online,
install my software.
So it's ready to go.
And then you have
an Autoscaler that
plugs into some kind of metric.
So you could use
something like CPU usage
across my cluster
of virtual machines.
So once my CPU starts
spiking on average,
start adding more at this rate.
Network traffic.
So if I start getting hammered
with a lot of network traffic,
scale up at this rate.
One of the things you can do
is you can tie it into Pub/Sub,
which we talked
about, and say, hey,
however many videos are
waiting to get processed,
spin up that many extractors.
Why not?
Our billing goes down to 10
minute increments rather than
an hour.
So it's actually
not that expensive.
Say we have 10 extractor
processes out there.
We're waiting for 10 videos.
But then 1,000 come
in all at once.
We could spin up to
1,000 extractors,
chop down all of
those super-quickly,
and then release
those extractors.
And that way, we can
scale up as quickly
as possible without
maintaining all that scale.
And it does it automatically.
This autoscaler and managed
template group do that for us
once we configure it.
So next, I'm going to talk
about containerization.
I'm going to breeze through
containers because we're
getting along in the talk.
But has anyone
heard of containers
or familiar with it all?
Yeah.
I think Brian may have a thing
or two to say about that.
So let me give you this
totally sweet continuum
of efficiency and flexibility.
So on the upper left,
you have Compute Engine,
which is our virtual
machine offering.
It is as flexible as
you need it to be.
It can literally do anything.
It's a virtual machine for
you to install whatever.
But you have to
manage it yourself.
You have to configure scaling.
You have to worry about scaling.
You have to provision them.
You have to install security
updates, and patches,
and things like that.
You have to manage it yourself.
So that's less efficient
as a developer.
On the bottom right, we have App
Engine, which I talked about.
Again, the dream of App Engine.
Write your code.
Here you go, App
Engine, run it for me.
I don't care about what you
have to do to make that happen.
I don't care how many
virtual machines you need.
I don't care what version
of the operating system
you're running on.
You are responsible for it.
But it's a little
bit less flexible.
So there's some trade-offs.
You can't run a process
longer than 60 seconds.
You can't write
to the local disk.
You can't do literally
everything you want.
So there are some trade-offs.
So there's got to be something
up here in the upper right
that's quite flexible
and quite efficient.
And we'll see what that is.
Incidentally, I don't
know what this gray box
is where it's not at
all flexible and not
at all efficient.
But I'm pretty sure we
used it at my last job.
Container Engine is Google's
container orchestration
offering.
So you might be asking,
well, what is a container?
Not everyone knows what a
container-- let me give you
the super-quick version.
And if you have
more questions, I
will be here afterwards
to talk to you about that.
So let's go back to the
olden days, way back when, of
say the early 2000s where you
just had a dedicated machine.
So if you're like
me, I had a startup
and I just had like one
machine literally under my desk
in a closet that was running
everything from my startup.
It was running our mail server.
It was running our web server.
It was running our database.
It was running all those.
So every app we had
was on our machine.
And it shared the same kernel.
And it shared the
same libraries.
Well, you run into a
few issues with that.
Specifically, around
sharing libraries
where maybe this
version of the app
needs this version
of the library.
This other app needs
a different version.
So sometimes they
step on each other.
If app tanks, it
takes everything down.
And that sucks.
So we then moved to a way
called virtual machines.
So this is each app gets
its own virtual machine-- so
its own set of libraries
and its own kernel.
And that's nice because
it's completely isolated.
If one of the apps tanks, it
doesn't take anything down.
You know what version of
everything you have is
because it's
dedicated to that app.
But it has a big drawback.
It's like you have a whole
OS just for this other app.
And that feels like a lot.
And you have to
manage it as if it
were its own dedicated machine.
So it's a huge
amount of overhead.
So that's a little
bit of overkill.
So we have containers.
This is the new
way, ta da, where
instead of a whole virtual
machine for each app,
they all share the
same OS kernel.
But they are isolated from each
other to appear to each app
as if it has its own OS,
but it doesn't really.
It's sort of a process
isolation model or analogy.
So each app has its own
libraries specific to it.
It could have any version
of whatever it wants.
It doesn't talk to
any of the other apps.
If one app tanks, it
doesn't take anything down.
But you don't have literally
a whole operating system.
So this gives you a couple
of advantages, one of which
is you can start up a
container super quickly,
like within seconds.
So imagine you need a
new virtual machine.
It literally has to boot up
a virtual machine, like boop,
starting, and you get all your
Linux startup scripts running.
So that takes a while.
But a container could start
up literally within seconds.
We have a whole demo-- I
won't, but I can show you--
that illustrates that.
So we would like to do
that, because as fast as it
is to spin up a virtual machine
on Google Compute Engine--
so like I said, within a minute
or two or three-- containers
are way faster.
Do I want to get into this?
So what is a container?
How does it work?
Or how do you define it?
It's also really nice.
That's my other half
of the sales pitch
for containers is that
you sort of declare
what the environment
is you want to run in.
So you say, I want to
run an Ubuntu version
X with PHP version Y with my
custom app code version Z.
And you declare it in
a configuration file.
And then you can run it in the
cloud with that configuration
file.
You can run it on your desktop
with that configuration file.
You can run it in QA,
staging, production.
It's all running off
of that same file.
So your app will behave the
exact same way everywhere,
because you have
defined declaratively
all your dependencies.
And that's really
nice because it
helps you avoid the problem
of-- it works on my machine.
And it works in
development environment.
And it works in staging.
But it don't work in production.
You can actually
say, I want them
to all have the exact
same runtime environment.
So hopefully, one day, we'll
put Cloud Spin into containers
using Container Engine--
it is in containers
now-- Container Engine,
which is Google's container
orchestration tool.
So hopefully, I didn't
bait and switch you
so you thought that it
was on Container Engine.
But it is in containers.
So we're almost done.
We're at the homestretch.
We've gotten all the way through
from App Engine Notification
Processor put into a queue.
We've extracted all the frames.
We've stitched
them all together.
Well, let me back up.
We haven't stitched
them all together.
So we've extracted
all the frames.
And we've put them into some
kind of temporary storage.
But we run into a problem.
And the problem is every
time an extractor is done,
it's putting a stitch message
into the stitch queue.
So the stitcher is constantly
getting something saying, hey,
stitch it together.
But it's getting that 20 times.
Because it's all
happening randomly
and in parallel, it's hard
for it to actually know,
when do I have all 20 frames?
So you can't just
wait till camera 20
is done because camera
20 could finish first.
And then it only has one frame.
And it can't stitch
one frame together.
So we have a database
also using Firebase
that keeps track of all the
frames and whether they're done
or not.
So once each extractor is
done-- so frame 1 is done,
frame 2 is done,
frame 8, frame 10,
and so forth-- it will get
updated in the database
and set its status to Ready.
Then when the stitcher gets its
message, it checks the database
and says, hey, are 20 done?
Yes or no?
So the first one is
no, the second one, no,
third, et cetera.
Once it gets to 20,
are all 20 done?
Yes.
It goes and pulls images out of
temporary storage and stitches
them together into
an animated GIF.
Hooray!
All right, so let me
run through the problems
that we're going to solve.
How do we get all the
cameras to take a photo
at the exact same moment?
We record a video,
and we play a beep
that plays at the exact
moment across all the phones.
How do we coordinate
all the phones?
Error messages,
status, so forth.
We use Firebase--
real-time database.
Where do we put the files?
Google Cloud Storage.
How do we scale?
We're using Pub/Sub
as a message queue
to absorb all those messages.
And then we're using Compute
Engine instance groups
to autoscale our
compute resources.
Where do we process our images?
A Compute Engine virtual machine
running our Python scripts.
How do we control costs?
We use the managed
instance groups
to keep our virtual machine
count as low as possible
until it needs to scale up.
How do we create
multiple versions?
We use Cloud Pub/Sub.
And we could have
different subscribers
listening to the same
events and then working
on different versions of
the final animated GIF.
And then I didn't
really talk about it,
but we can use
Google Cloud Logging
to keep track of everything.
So we've got a bunch of
different pieces of the system.
And they can all log to one
central logging location,
which is Google Cloud Logging.
So we have one
place to see what's
going on with our system.
All right, so I have a demo of
Cloud Spin in action, a video.
But as luck would
have it, we actually
have the rig right here.
So why don't we do an
untested live demo?
I say untested because we
had it working this morning
and we literally
haven't touched it.
So here's hoping
that it still works.
All right, Mark, you want
to be our guinea pig?
All right.
This my colleague Mark.
Give him a hand everyone, yes.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, would you like a toy?
Do you know what
you're going to?
MARK: I have no idea.
BRETT MCGOWEN: All
right, just wing it.
Tara, are you ready?
MARK: Might as well jump, yes.
TARA: All right,
whenever you're ready.
On the word go.
And go.
BRETT MCGOWEN: All right.
So we have this handy
dandy little visualizer.
So we can see what's happening.
It's going to walk us
through the process.
So this represents each camera.
So right now, they're uploading.
They're gray.
This is the where we
pray to the gods of Wi-Fi
that they don't hose me over.
So it's uploading.
All right, come on.
Show me the first one.
All right, I wish I had some
jokes to tell right now.
Oh, here we go.
Yes.
So once it starts spinning,
that means it has now
made it into the cloud.
And it's actually processing
and extracting that one frame.
So, again, it's looking
through the whole video
and it's finding the frame
where that beep existed.
This is going to be a good one.
So you can see, again, it's
all happening asynchronously,
just random times
that it finishes
uploading and random times
it actually gets the image.
And then once we
have them all, it's
going to go to that
stitcher process
to stitch them all together.
All right, only
three more to go.
Just one.
[GROANS] Come on, here we go.
There we go.
Yay!
All right.
Thanks, Mark.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you, Tara, for
driving the control app.
All right, so we built a
lot in just three weeks.
And we focused a lot
of the time on coding.
Almost everything I showed
you from a cloud perspective
is a managed service by Google.
So the least managed bit
of that is Compute Engine,
which is our actual
virtual machine
that we installed
the Python scripts on
to process the image.
Most of our time was
either in the Android app
working on that experience
or working on the code
to extract the images,
to analyze the video,
so in other words,
sort of the core
features of our application.
And that's the message
I want to leave you
with is that we have a lot
of managed services in cloud
at Google for the
Google Cloud platform.
That means you
don't have to worry
about a lot of that
infrastructure.
It can scale for you.
It can handle network
traffic for you.
It can absorb those in a queue.
There's a lot of
stuff that you don't
have to worry--
that you don't want
to worry about as a developer.
You want to spend your time
sort of like this Android
guy working on that app
and in image processing.
So there's a whole
bunch of stuff
that I threw at you
just pretty much
like half of what we offer.
So if you have any more
questions about any of those,
myself and a bunch of
my teammates are here.
We would love to talk to you,
answer any of your questions,
and most importantly, come
get your own Cloud Spin.
We will have this running from
the minute I finish, which
is almost here, till
this evening sometime
kind of when it dies
down in the after party.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
And I maybe have a couple
of minutes for questions,
actually.
Anybody have questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I've
noticed in some of them,
like the sample you
did just a moment ago,
there is still some jitter.
So do you think that
given enough tuning time,
you'd be able to get
rid of the jitter?
BRETT MCGOWEN: Yeah.
So the question is there's still
a little bit of jitter in that.
And that can be
caused by two things.
One is alignment of the cameras.
So it is a very manual
process that we align them.
We literally-- actually, we
took two tables, stacked them
on top of each other.
We marked a pole.
And on the viewfinder, there's
like these cross hairs.
And we aligned the cross
hairs, literally manually,
like moving the phone in
the mount to line them up.
So that's pretty imperfect.
The second is the
video we're taking
is 30 frames per second,
which is actually
less than 20 seconds--
it's worse than 20 seconds
difference.
So we actually still can
end up with some jitter.
So what we could do
is actually record
a 60 frame per second video.
That would get us
more precision to find
that one frame more precisely.
Realistically, the main
reason we didn't do that is it
takes a while to upload
on the Wi-Fi as it is.
So if we doubled the file size,
it would take a long time.
So there's some of that.
We also have some sort of image
smoothing, image stabilization
algorithms that we
can run on that.
We're still fiddling with that
because what that tends to do
is it finds all the
common areas of the images
and then overlays them
and then crops out
anything that is outside
of the area that's
common to everything.
But what that tends to do
is zoom in way on the image.
So you end up with a lot of
Cloud Spins with people's heads
cut off and things like that.
So that's an algorithmic
thing that we're working on
to make it a little bit better.
So mostly, it's
precision in the number
of frames in the video and
then just manual alignment.
I mean, people bump the rig
and that moves the cameras
and things like that.
There are more aggressive
ways we can smooth that.
But it also tends to
introduce a lot of artifacting
into the image
where there's things
like your elbow
is like super-long
or whatever to get that going.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What are the
best case and worst case
and conventional latency
you get on the Firebase
synchronization?
BRETT MCGOWEN: Yeah.
So the question is
latency in Firebase.
What's the best
case, worst case?
I don't want to promise you.
But I feel like typically,
it's around 100 milliseconds,
maybe a little less.
That's if you're
looking for something
to ballpark what it
feels like normally,
which is pretty quick.
So it's not necessarily fast
enough to tell all these phones
with Firebase,
take a picture now.
But it gets close.
So a lot of games are
written with Firebase.
And latency, of
course, as you know,
is super-important
in that respect.
So we have collaborative
drawing apps and things.
And as you draw, you
could see it translate
on someone else's computer.
So it's pretty quick.
Any other questions?
All right.
Again, thank you guys so much.
And come get a Cloud Spin.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC  PLAYING]